June 2016 you said we can get net
migration down to 50 000 yes of course
now whether you want it's a Glenn Boris
Johnson of course we'll look at that and
say yes I believe this guy yes I believe
this guy yes I voted for it because of
this guy
and this guy let me down this guy didn't
tell me the truth I wasn't if you put if
if they put me in charge of it would
have got to 30 000 a year what would be
your solution in the short term would
you close off the borders and have
worker shortages in the UK to in order
to drive net migration if that meant if
that meant there was a realistic chance
of people finding somewhere to live
school for their kids to go to that was
local people getting access to the
National Health Service then yes of
course and some voters might look at and
think you were dishonest when you were
promising stuff that you could never
deliver you know what I might have got
things right I might have got things
wrong over my years in politics I would
like to think hand on heart I was never
dishonest